but so the question asked you in part
about the other things that you bring to
the table and you talked about Justin's
Justin Nance blastin Dustin the play
writing eight so there is a value to
bringing his talent to this if if you
could hazard quantifying all of the
non-financial components to this the
grand strategy of producing as you said
this moment of change what would that be
it would be in you know to steal from
the visa commercial commercial priceless
you can't put a price on that and that's
why you you know you want that you can
you can you can raise money to you're
blue in the face but if you're not
spending it in an exciting
world-changing way if you're not
bringing the big ideas to it and if
you're not pulling in the creative
talent to really move people then you
know you're not going to win I mean your
issue that's that's sort of i think in a
lot of ways that's what it comes down to
the it's been it's a perennial problem
with civil rights movements and it's
been a huge problem with the LGBT
movement preaching to the converted and
you end up you know and milk was it you
know is it is a good example I mean you
know the gays and lesbians and liberals
and city people saw that movie in droves
and it moved them and it they wept and
they came out just as supportive of the
gay rights movement as they were when
they went in you know did we did we
change hearts and minds did we get to
the home of the homophobes did we get to
the people who were disgusted by gay
people and maybe milk might have changed
their mind well that's hard to quantify
I mean yes we in in anecdotally
absolutely we did in some cases because
we would get cards and letters from
around the country and you know I
dragged my uncle or I brought my
relative or you know so to some extent
we did more imp
partly the core group who sees it and
who's moved and inspired I mean actually
milk the movie sort of helped birth this
whole next generation of LGBT activists
all these kids who rebelled against the
established organizations and went out
and started changing the world on their
own so yeah the impact is huge but it
didn't for milk ended up doing 40
million dollars at the domestic box
office brokeback mountain by comparison
did 110 million at the domestic box
office so weirdly because actually I
like if you're if you're squier
squeamish about gay stuff there's
actually more just weird you out in
brokeback mountain than there is in milk
but way more straight people saw
Brokeback Mountain Way more conservative
PeopleSoft Brokeback Mountain Way more
Republican so Brokeback Mountain Way
more homophobes saw Brokeback Mountain
Way more everyone so Brokeback Mountain
which is kind of weird too because it
just things just reduce you know ended
its core level Brokeback Mountain like
had sex and was like a love story and
milk was political and the guy got shot
and that's just a you know you only have
one movie you're seeing on Friday nights
so but so 8 is these unquantifiable
things that you're talking about where
you're sort of bringing your talent and
you're taking from the what you do is
your day job and trying to bring it to
the movement you know the the hope
always is twofold that it's going to
inspire the choir but that it's going to
reach out and change people's minds